the Joe Rogan experience when you
entered the fifth round against Kelvin
you said I'm ready to die and was I
looked at him and I remember I call it
este Diablo he was looking at me and he
just had this like look and he's just
swinging his hands and I said you're not
gonna beat me I'm prepared to die and I
meant that man I swear to God on my life
I meant that I'm even getting goosebumps
thinking see that huh like I meant that
[ __ ] cuz I was like look and I sign I
signed my death warrant right now as I
look if this is how I died this is how I
die but you see me I was trying to get
him I was trying to kill him I knew cuz
for me if I'm ready to die I'm ready to
kill you have to be willing to give
something up as well so in that fifth
round when I was throwing those shots
when I was I think I dropped him like
four times or something crazy like even
the last one like went from heaven hit
him I wish I didn't like follow and like
roll over on them because I probably
could have got him out with like two
seconds left but I was trying to get him
out of there then and it's sad to say
but I was ready if he had taken it to me
and he had done that to me and I didn't
wake up so be it
well that was evident in the way you
fought because you did you didn't you
know was a close fight but it looked
like you were ahead on the judges but
you didn't take I mean any break at all
you know you just you threw yourself
into the fire instead of being cautious
you know and I told that to Dana you
know Dana and I were talking about that
fight and he was he was talking about
hype Diaz for Whitaker they try to get
me to fly to Australia
me try it like right now I've cancelled
a lot of my trips because also you know
my knee but also just formal being away
from the gym
like you feel it after a while shows
level like after the fight cuz you can
see the target on your back people smile
in your face you know oh yeah and then
yeah I know what's up I'm not stupid
I've seen a lot of people in this game
rising for 100% all the time so I want
to get back to doing what I do best you
promise that to me people like like can
live a social media free life and still
make money doing it real hard Dave does
it yeah he's one of the only people that
I know that does but he's so intelligent
about that kind of [ __ ] he doesn't
engage in that he doesn't engage in
other people's opinions of him he's like
he
my phone does he he don't use his phone
he the dirtiest phone up there anything
so should me whatever he want to see
through my phone he checks it out to you
oh my [ __ ] addicted to
worldstar Izzie yeah we'd be on the road
man we'd be on a vote all you see always
some I can rant about he's all worlds
too hard
that's a lair but anything that's
dealing with pop culture and stuff like
that are you I'm usually like they did
like the guy just brings him into it but
does he just keep no fault no apps on
his phone I don't think I don't think he
has app good for him yeah good for him
it's a good I lost a phone the other day
man and I was saying to myself I was
freaking out because you know if you
lose a [ __ ] for the minute you do the
pocket check mm-hmm you do like all four
pockets in the first thing you say is
[ __ ] right and if you the worst thing is
a person that's going when you're going
out with a group of people and a person
lose a phone just ruined the whole
[ __ ] night yeah because then you
gotta go [ __ ] search for it all right
be quiet
call my phone right call my phone could
y'all be quiet cuz ya'll call my phone
cuz ya'll call and I told myself I was
like [ __ ] cuz I'm I got the UM iCloud
and [ __ ] now so it's not as [ __ ]
tragic as it used to be like your phone
you losing your kid being born and all
this stuff and I lost the phone and I
was like [ __ ] I just lost my four months
ago
I lost the [ __ ] phone I was like you
know what Daniel you can't let your
phone [ __ ] regulate your life like
that you a person be on that phone I
went to sleep right now his sleep was it
was so peaceful and I woke up and the
first thing I want to know was what time
it was right and I didn't think to look
at a watch or anything I was like where
the [ __ ] is my phone and I went right
back and got a phone I did ten hours out
of phone I was about to go crazy
how do people [ __ ] do this how do you
find out directions
Ari Shaffir went without a phone for
four months for it was a reality show
no he just yeah it was his own reality
show he just decided to go to Asia he
traveled all around Asia went to like he
went to Vietnam yeah but he was already
loaded
yeah yeah yeah you don't just you
you just don't have like a minimum-wage
job but just leave your mom for four
months no you kinda can't now wu-tang
was designed right to come together for
a common cause
right and that cause of course being to
express our art to rise ourselves out of
poverty and the feed our family so that
was that was a foundation but it's not
designed to fall apart
in fact whoo tang that's why on our
second album it's called wu-tang forever
breath meaning no matter what we do no
matter if I go make movies or Method Man
make movies or you go write books you
come back together yeah we always better
come back this forever
but hold on me finish last night but now
they put us all on the same like to
expose it all to the world through
warrant outlet yeah that it had to be
that it had to be that and the reason
why I said it cuz I had my schedule I
have my schedule years ago Scott's
secret society when I was doing remember
that I had this manager and she kept
this was before the day she fell show
everything I was like I'm watching you
bro look and I'm and then I said uh I
said I'm one of the managers working
with she was like the name our crew was
secret society she said I had Mike Epps
I had mafia why drag ran so bad my
father and and she said Daniel
I think secret site is falling apart I
said [ __ ] it was supposed to fall apart
it was supposed to fall apart but what
his fault
whether it was fault does it land
somewhere you could grow something else
like I knew it was only three people
that were gonna be stars but it was four
other people that were gonna be writers
right right it was two other enough
[ __ ] that was gonna be it was a
different [ __ ] but we needed dad okay I
got you in there so so force will fall
apart that world
you said fall apart I didn't mean it
like you made more like spread his wings
yeah and like even though like when I
said that I mean it like even though
like everybody for the most part
everybody want to be a superstar
everybody had the chops everybody wasn't
a superstar right and it's proven to
this day some people's like this can
sweat this [ __ ] and wrote on
eight different shows we won right
this dude is toured in Europe we want
exactly you know I'm saying it was like
when I say fall apart it was like it was
gonna go to here and then it was just
gonna be like if all I did yo you know
it was good we
all got it that they're strong enough
could they that they exist independently
of different areas but I always come
back together if they're not to leave
the individual out of it and ask how
much social damage is caused by any of
those things okay in alcohol in act
number one by a by a bullet yeah yeah
you know what's amazing to me is how the
people who make alcohol have get a free
ride it's incredible to me like if I
said to you that I was on the board of
Philip Morris you would say that's
Malcolm that's pretty screwed up yeah
and you would you would be you know a
problem with it if I said that oh I'm
you know I'm on the board of
anheuser-busch you probably would hit me
up for tickets to the Super Bowl mmm
right is that the same whereas there's
no in terms of the amount of social
damage what out what anheuser-busch has
created has produced a hundred times the
social damage than what Philip Morris
has produced Yeah right like our you
know so it's like it's a it's always
puzzled about I don't know how it got it
in our heads like to treat one like it's
completely taboo and the other we kind
of shrug you know the there are bunch I
was reading about this recently how many
colleges except not just except alcohol
advertising and sponsorship but you go
to a college football game and you know
Bud Light will have will be an active
sponsor of the event we'll have some
huge relationship with the school this
is crazy we it's crazy right it's like
this is the drug that is causing so many
problems for young people particularly
on campuses and the schools are hand in
glove with the manufacturers of it
because it's socially acceptable because
they don't have to worry about
repercussions because we gave it up we
gave it a in a way that they would never
have Marlboro Marlboro yeah oh my god
people would pick it yeah whereas it's
not you know I don't know that's true
it's a strange kind of we were so messy
people are so messy and that is that
that's a very good example of how messy
we are yeah he's nuts
the best he's just funny it's just a way
to live
he made Norton and and and Florentine
introduced him like they go into a
Subway sandwich shop and the book
ladies and gentlemen avert your eyes the
ledger just coming in and he was like
walk-in program my sandwich shop
that's hilarious yeah that would be a
great show
you have just dice on the road and
someone announces him like that
everywhere he goes yeah peasants please
the legend clear the floor behind me
from his house for a year once would you
do I do
energy doses kids I did not know I would
never do that
mostly I'm scared of dice he said he had
a gun in his in his desk drawer and I
was like no you don't no way you would
never have him around your kids because
I do and he said he'd bet me $200 and
I'm like you know I don't have $200 so I
can't make that bet and he goes on it
well I do
and then he's three Saul left his thing
and goes don't look in there I'm like
I'm not gonna look in there he goes
don't [ __ ] look in there but I won't
and then Freddy Soto [ __ ] [ __ ]
Freddy Soto
[ __ ] told him I was just in the
office told him that I went into his
drawer he said I was rifling through his
drawers and dice like that's it it's a
lie who's a lie by Freddy Soto and dives
like you're out you're banned from the
house could've are because anymore yeah
I was rifling through his appearance
which never happened dice I never did
that I was in the room why do you think
Freddy did that
well of course cuz of that reason cuz
he's that because he got me banned he
wanted to get you back yeah
why do you what I think Freddy would
wanna get you banned I think he was
jealous of my upbringing and how I had a
foosball table at home and it always
bothered him that he didn't have that
growing up in Texas interesting maybe
interesting I'm not sure but the point
is I never read those Affairs but how
many people in the urban
low lower income you know impoverished
population suffering from PTSD who don't
can't afford to go to Johns Hopkins to
spend tens of thousands of dollars to
have a clinical treatment I think this
democratizes the the use of Sullivan and
micro dosing that could be a benefit
across our society and then why I'm
proposing is you stock up with niacin
and the reason why you stock up with
niacin is you take 1/10 of a gram of /b
cubensis microdose you had 102
milligrams of niacin now if someone
tries to get high by taking ten times as
much they'll have like two grams of
niacin this is flushing niacin vitamin
b3 and that flushing nice and will give
you such an irritable reaction of skin
itching of people who've taken vitamin B
they three they know this so it becomes
the antabuse for micro dosing but
moreover it excites the nerves at the
end of the peripheral nervous system and
neuropathy is oftentimes present
themselves a deadening of the fingertip
the nerves of the fingertips and toes
and it's also a vasodilator so there's
three attributes of stacking niacin with
suicide mushrooms that prevents abuse
becomes the antabuse it dilates the
blood vessels to deliver the neurogenic
benefits of psilocybin to the endpoints
of the peripheral nervous system and the
central nervous system and it then and
also excites the nerve endings so I
think those three reasons this could be
I hope to see in the future silicide
mushroom coming over-the-counter
vitamins approved by the FDA stack with
niacin that allows for the universality
of use Jamie pointed this out that
there's a congressman and he released a
series of tweets and the first letter of
all these tweets if you put them all
together it says Epstein didn't kill
himself or did not count so know what it
is it's didn't he did how did the
Apostle should have gone with did not
start in here with that evidence of a
link wrapped Paul gaw sir what are the
odds this guy did this accidentally
really small right that's kind of like
one of those monkeys typing Shakespeare
say yeah yeah I don't think I could it
could work and the thing is he did it
backwards right so you didn't see what
the puzzle was until the last tweet
because the last time he does in e I got
a tweet from someone about 35 minutes
ago that I don't know if there's a bunch
of people online paying attention to it
or what but someone did me and a few
other people what it is yeah does he
have an image of that [ __ ] that crazy
mask is that in his [ __ ] too okay he's
got the I was November first V mask
yes yeah what is that mask your Vendetta
wasn't represented
was something it's the Guy Fawkes mask
yes that's right yeah so this guy's he's
he's thinking long alternative lines of
thought but that is really an
interesting way of saying it
alphabet tree that's yeah just making a
bunch of tweets don't ever address it
just leave it there walk away you know
Lewis Carroll was famous for that was he
yeah that was one of uh he did a lot of
sort of tricks with words you read the
book gödel Escher Bach No yeah there's
there's a whole bunch of stuff in there
about people who used who put puzzles in
text mmm you know it's kind of a thing
that people did I guess back more in the
18th century in before
well this Epstein case is probably the
most blatant example of a public murder
of a crucial witness I've ever seen in
my entire life or anybody's ever seen
and the the the minimal amount of
outrage about this the no minimal amount
of cover it's [ __ ] fascinating I mean
I what's amazing to me just as a you
know somebody works in the media is that
this was shaping up to be the biggest
like news story in history yes and the
instant he you know he died or was died
or however you want to call it it's the
story just fell off the face of the
earth
yeah it's like nobody's doing anything
about it and I I don't
100% understand that I mean I get it why
that's happening but it's it's just
amazing well
[Applause]